as we get ready for tomorrow special
live audience show stop the stigma a
conversation about mental health we were
focusing on the mental health of mothers
Grammy award-winning singer Alanis
Morissette is sharing her nearly
decade-long experience with postpartum
depression in an essay on her website
the 45 year old revealed she's dealing
with the condition for a third time
she said she's having sleep deprivation
fogginess physical pain isolation and
anxiety according to the American psyche
yet psychological association up to one
in seven women experienced postpartum
depression which can appear days or even
months after delivering a baby
Mireya Villarreal spoke to Morissette
Maria good morning why did she want to
share her experience
well good morning Toni ìletís Morissette
believes many women don't get enough
emotional support after childbirth she
told me that postpartum depression can
feel like you're covered in tar and then
underwater the singer hopes that by
sharing her experience she can help
other moms
[Music]
her songs are filled with raw emotion
expressing the feelings of a generation
of music lovers
[Music]
now Alanis Morissette is using her voice
to bring attention to an issue she knows
well postpartum depression
this time around it's less depression
it's more anxiety and a little more of
the compulsive obsessive thoughts when
you talk about invasive thoughts like
yeah what does that include though I
mean images that are horrifying just a
lot of times about safety about the
people you love your loved ones your
children and then you just having to
remind myself like oh no this is just
postpartum depression swooping in again
stop in a candid online essay the mother
of three opens up about dealing with
postpartum for a third time following
the birth of her son winner mercy in
August she writes postpartum depression
or PPD is still a sneaky monkey with a
machete working its way through my
psyche
there's something about chronicling the
experience in real time if the goal is
stigma free perception of any mental
illness or mental health conversation
understanding and giving the details of
what it really looks like from the
inside is important the Grammy Award
winning singer first realized she was
dealing with postpartum 16 months after
the birth of her first child in 2010 my
survival strategy is to just push
through and then I spoke with a
professional who who knew all about
postpartum depression I asked her does
this go away if I just wait knuckle
through it she said no it actually gets
worse so as soon as I heard that I
thought it can't get worse than this so
then I I went on medication right away
Morissette also approaches her recovery
in part by meditating leaning on loved
ones and turning to a familiar passion
music
[Music]
when I'm in any state emotionally sad
angry freaked out lonely isolated
depressed I can write thank God for that
are there moments where you're like it's
gone I'm cured there are moments where I
think it's gonna be kind of easy or I do
get a little cocky but I don't think of
it in terms of cured because I know that
postpartum isn't something that lasts a
week you know for me it's it's at least
two years maybe a little longer signs a
postpartum depression can include
anxiety or panic attacks uncontrolled
crying or sadness fear of being left
alone with the baby or lack of interest
in the baby altogether the American
Psychological Association recommends
that anyone experiencing symptoms for
more than two weeks seek help if left
untreated the condition can last many
weeks or months was ever a moment where
that fear made you want to say I can't
do it again no because I'd experience
the other side of postpartum depression
and having this relationship I know that
there's a light at the end of the tunnel
I'd be willing to go through it again I
know that sounds a little insane but you
know I'm willing to present sacrifice
for future gain it I've done it a
million times
Morissette has also some advice for
family and friends she actually
recommends welcoming moms who've just
given birth with open arms and no
expectation saying just showing up can
make a huge difference to these moms so
interesting to hear her say that she
wanted to white-knuckle through it but
was advised worst thing we all do that
I'll just feel like I can get through
this on my own I don't need help I can
make it it's it's fine it's fine it's a
love her description of it a sneaky
monkey old Alanis Morrisette I mean out
with those raw lyrics absolutely Maria
we have to say too about you first I
have to say Bravo and thank you because
you also opened up about something very
personal I had no idea this was going on
in your life you talk about having a
miscarriage while you're live on the air
in your reporting and you write about it
is honestly must-see must-see reading
for everybody who's
listening to you at this moment because
you said at the time was I really having
a miscarriage in the middle of a
wildfire no one around to hug me can die
save the baby can a doctor come to the
top of the hill to check me out and one
of the crew guys says maybe you're just
as you've eaten a bad burrito because
they didn't know that you were probably
didn't know and I think that as women
you just again like what Elana said you
just want to prove yourself you want to
just show everybody that you can do this
and so for me I wrote this not ever
thinking it would go anywhere didn't
know where I would put it and then I had
this moment with Alanis and I just knew
that there were other moms out there or
there want to be moms
I never go in Chariton it's on our
website Maria thank you thank you we'll
be right back